what makes an executive hire a writer
well there's a couple of different
things that they would hire them for
if somebody is pitching a show I mean my
expertise is primarily television but a
lot of this applies to Motion Pictures
also to features
if
someone is pitching it and they nail the
pitch
they're going to want to be in business
with them
if there's somebody who if an executive
is in charge of finding writers to be on
a television show
if you have a meeting with that person
they want to know that you're not a
psycho they want to they will have read
you and they will think this is a
terrific writer now let me see if I can
get along with them let me see if the
showrunner I'm thinking of for the show
they would be right for would get along
with them
those are the reasons why somebody would
hire that's why an executive would hire
a writer
one of the most important elements of a
pitch
well it's interesting because pitching
is an art it's not a science and I have
an online course called how to pitch a
TV show that sells and we talk all about
this but the important elements are
the characters
that's super important how the
characters are going to grow and change
over the pilot and then over the series
people think that the pilot story is the
most important thing and it's not
because you're not just selling a pilot
you're selling a series so it is
What The Hook is that's super important
why are people going to watch it why are
they watch it now why will it stand out
from 500 plus other scripted television
shows you gotta have a strong hook
then it's tell me about the world also
it's really important in a pitch and you
talk about this earlier in another video
is
having a personal story that ties you to
that project
it's not like you just said oh wouldn't
it be funny if uh there was a roller
coaster and it was haunted you have to
and I'm a terrible I'm not a writer
which is why I just gave that terrible
example
um but
you have to connect with it somehow when
I was home alone one night
I was sure that a ghost was there and I
was terrified and I thought what if
somebody is terrified of that and
terrified on a roller coaster too find a
way to make an emotional connection with
them and find that emotional connection
in the project and use that to connect
with the buyer if you tell an authentic
emotional story they will be hooked in
so it's the hook it's what I call your
inspiration story why you why this
project it is talking about the
characters why they're unique why we
haven't seen them before it's about the
world what does that world look like you
want to paint it you want us to feel it
tell us why we want to be immersed into
it for 40 hours
super important what is the engine of
the show if it's a TV show
why does this have legs past just the
pilot and season arcs are really
important and knowing what that is and
then you have something that I call a
coda which is a concluding remark where
you go back to your hook
and then you say why people will watch
it why it's timely why it's Universal
why now
how long is a pitch to an executive what
should a writer think about in
preparation great question
some people think it goes on forever it
doesn't if you're pitching television a
comedy pitch should be 12 to 15 minutes
long
a one hour drama or one hour show it
should be 20 to 25 minutes no longer
unless your Sean Ryan who just sold
agent night you know night agent
um
20 to 25 minutes and on Zoom should be
shorter
you should rehearse your pitch you
should time your pitch you should come
in on those times and
the again the pilot story is only a very
small portion of that
10 to 15 10 to 12 minutes or 20 to 25
minutes
and and record yourself giving the pitch
absolutely
and I know somebody who's a terrific
pitcher and what she said is and this is
what I believe you write out the pitch
word for word
then you transcribe it into bullet
points
and then you practice using the bullet
points some people read their pitch
if you're a good performer you can read
your pitch but make it sound
conversational a good pitch is
conversational for sure
um so write it practice it record
yourself so that you can hear the pacing
in it so you've got that right so you
can time it I had a mentee in my CBS
program who was fantastic in my program
you have to
introduce yourself 16 times because
they're 16 weeks and people got to the
point the writers got to the point where
it sounded totally rehearsed
but Bradley
had a way to make it sound like it was
the first time every time and the way he
did it is he would say something and
then he'd pause for a beat as if he was
actually thinking about what the next
thing was he was going to say and he had
some funny parts to a story and he would
chuckle a little bit you know not like
that laugh out loud but you know just
kind of chuckle so that they could
chuckle with him
and his introductions always sounded
like they were off the cuff you want
this to sound like it's off the cuff
but you know it backwards and forwards
so with he's he's telling a little bit
about himself and then the pitch well
Bradley wasn't pitching that that was
just
it's a 16-week program and every week I
bring in different speakers and the
writers have to just introduce
themselves to each of the speakers I'm
sorry if that was confusing no no that's
I find that interesting okay so they're
kind of practicing that that because we
all don't really want to talk about
ourselves sometimes so it's like hi I'm
so and so and this is my deal and is
that it so you're comfortable kind of
owning who you are yes I teach them I
mean that's one of the things I teach is
your entertainment industry brand and
you need to know how to talk about
yourself in a way that is engaging and
gets people leaning forward and wanting
to know more so I teach that to the
mentees in the Paramount writers
mentoring program and over 16 weeks they
hone it and hone it and hone it so that
by the end of the 16 weeks they can talk
about themselves like that and Bradley
was just a champ at it what are some
common mistakes that you see in pitches
oh I love that question because there's
so many mistakes that people make sadly
it's sad when you make this mistake is
not being prepared is going in and
thinking I can wing it now here's the
truth there's some stand-up comics
there's some
improv people that really can but unless
you're that person you can't you should
be they're not prepared enough
the other is going beat by beat
by beat of the pilot story
there's a sad story that I like to tell
from when I was an executive
a very well established comedy writer
came in and pitched to us and he was
talking about the pilot story and he was
going beat by beat by beat and my
colleague fell asleep it was horrifying
um and he said to my boss the writer
said to my boss he fell asleep and my
boss said no no he's just resting his
eyes so he can hear you better but
that's something you don't want to do go
beat by it's it's overview you want to
give the big picture not every single
scene
what's the difference between telling
versus selling I have a mantra that I
believe in so strongly it's tell don't
sell
if you're desperate if you're there just
to sell the project
chances are really good you won't
you should be there to do is to tell an
engaging exciting funny or moving story
and what I tell people is pretend that
you're talking to a five-year-old your
whole vibe should be once upon a time
not well this is about this but once
upon a time in a forest there was
that's how you know you're telling
and selling is oh man I gotta tell you
this is the best thing you ever heard of
and it's going to be great and
it's a terrible idea
so add an element of performance
absolutely okay but even if you're not a
natural born performer and I do talk
about this in my class if you know your
material well enough
and you're comfortable enough you'll be
able to talk about it as if you were
talking to a friend and you don't need
to do
just you're yourself but it's like
you're talking to friends and you're
comfortable and it's upbeat and it's
engaging that's all you need to be